Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports Radio host Fox
Sports one contributor joining us on the
program good morning Doug thanks for
joining us I'll give you a minute here
tell me why you're against this rule
wait paper play it's not has nothing to
do it name and likeness and the program
no wait a minute
paper play who's paying explain them
well
well whoever has the idea this for your
name image and likeness and has a value
it's just not accurate without being
tied to the University it was high
school basketball players could go right
to the G League could command whatever
they want to deal to you know other any
other Joe's Chevy dealership whatever
they don't have that ability
additionally the biggest issue I had
with Gavin Newsom is and it's it's a
narrative that he's echoing it's not
something he came up his players get
nothing in the state of California when
I pay taxes in the one that he currently
runs it's knowing a logical it's just a
lie
Cal Berkeley which is running at a
massive deficit in their athletic
department and UCLA to the greatest
institutions the United States and my
guess would be 95 percent if not more of
the revenue-generating athletes at those
schools
Cal best public school in America UCLA
95 percent would not get in on the road
so first there's a value in just getting
it especially in the state of California
because the California schools do just
like any school like this idea will they
make money off their athletes hey here's
a newsflash schools make money off of
all of their students and they don't pay
taxes on it so the idea is they're
making money off their athletes they are
they're making gobs and gobs of money
off all of their students and then when
their students graduate they ask for
donations so the cycle can continue but
the state of California selling hard to
get in but they're the athletic
departments are barely being funded by
the state and so they're it's not
they're having trouble making ends meet
but supporting all of the different
athletic program
is an issue so once you start this idea
of hey there's gonna be professionals
let's go back he says they don't get
anything so a getting into cow getting
the academic and athletic support you
get while you're at cow and then
finishing up with a degree from the best
public public university in the country
has no value that's the biggest problem
we have the big heart we have in our
country is education inequality and all
of a sudden how the leaders who are
supposed to be fighting for that are
propelling it and saying it has no value
well it does and he you know what he
misspoke on that I think that's wrong
well it's wrong no it's I'm saying that
that's wrong I shouldn't say misspoke
that's wrong because you do get
something you do get an education you
get something very very valuable
absolutely but we're talking about where
are we headed with this Doug you have
certain Zion Williamson could have had
his own shoe at Duke Nike could pay him
whatever they wanted to yes okay look
zion.t misen was popular because YouTube
that doesn't support a guy's dick but
you and I would would have Bri that
playing what 20 games to Duke and
probably the way in which he tore up his
Nike yes and the way in which he put and
the way in which he played Duke North
Carolina he wouldn't have a Gatorade
deal if he didn't play a Duke he went to
the number one pick and fast he didn't
play it all of these things away we look
at die Winston's completely different no
I don't think that is true i I don't
think that listen you know as many can
be a people as I do okay go up and ask
them say hey what did you think as I
Williamson when he walked out mcdonald's
practice your before and they would have
said looks like a linebacker don't know
if he's an NBA player but I want to keep
an eye on it and now people are saying
he could have a LeBron type of impact
now is that his improvement absolutely
but he was also blessed by the fact that
he played for Duke in the biggest games
with the most respected coach arguably
in the history of the sport like all of
the like we're acting like this doesn't
have value and oh yeah by the way like
this really isn't about Zion it's you're
throwing at the bay the baby with the
bathwater
for the 1% of 1% that might have a value
on the open market all the rest of the
kids don't and you're running the risk
of one
in the athletic department and into and
this is most importantly if you become a
professional everything gets taxed like
that's the whole thing the reason this
thing works is because it's a non-profit
and nobody pays taxes on anything and
the second that they start taxing
athletic profits the second all of those
Olympic sports all of these things that
we've been fighting for any quality they
all go away and it becomes and we have
professional sports and I think really
that's the step that was taken by these
governors like what gavin newsom wants
to legalize of course he does he
legalized pot why because they want to
tax it yeah because they keep spending
money and not worrying about their
budget that's that's what happens in
government in big state government but
also what's going to stop a booster from
saying hey or if you're a recruit let's
say a football recruit and I have you
for three years and I you go to that
school because the booster pays the
starting quarterback a million dollars
to go to his car dealership a lot right
I mean that's where it gets to be paid
to play right I don't think it'll be I
don't think how do you cap that how do
you monitor that that if I that's a
problem that's a problem all traffic you
can't bother you just can't oh I have
concerns about this I'm not gonna you
know stamp of approval rubber stamp this
at all I have concerns about it but I
understand there are certain athletes at
certain times that are different than
everybody else they should be able to
capitalize on their likeness
ninety-eight percent of the other
athletes won't be capitalizing on their
likeness but there are going to be
boosters they'll be situated whatever
there's money there's corrupt and I I
think that that's that's what I'm
worried about that hey it's open season
for me here's that you'd like people
like to bring up Johnny Manziel okay and
like look Johnny Manziel was a thing at
am now maybe they were able to sell
their Suites quicker but there hasn't an
empty seat at am for or since Johnny
Manziel has been the same energy that
has been an empty seat four or six
here's the thing could he get
capitalized in the short term on his
jersey sales sure but because of the
promotion of playing am when they
promoted him for the Heisman playing on
CBS and playing on ESPN that Johnny
Manziel who by his own account
in failed in his NFL career in his head
all kinds of his own personal issues he
can write a book he can do it everyone
the whole rest of his life he's John
Manziel from Kerrville Texas who went
from fourth in the depth chart to
winning a Heisman Trophy okay you do
capitalize you're like this for the rest
of your life yeah you make it seem like
am producing Doug Doug am didn't am
didn't produce of Johnny means nobody's
talking about A&M football no one
they they they gave him the platform I
can give you the platform that doesn't
mean that you're you know no question
okay so no question but but this is no
different than any other student at
Harvard who can remove themselves for
you you know whatever Bill Gates you
start you know you start a company and
you leave Harvard and you go on to
brighter bigger and brighter things like
that's not what we're doing here we're
doing here is your trip you provide
trying to provide education and it's not
just about what you learned in schools
we all know it's about who you meet the
people you're around and those the
resource you'll have like I just we we
act like these guys get a terrible deal
they get into a school they couldn't get
into they get complete academic and
athletic support by the way now we put a
little bit of money in their pockets
many of these kids also can apply for
other grants so the heavy more money in
the pockets they stay in the best
facilities we have ridiculous support
for us and then by the way when they
leave I don't know if you know this you
can always come back now with you know
it's a scholarship for life you can come
back you can get a masters degree and
while you're getting a degree you can
also be on the floor on the field
coaching like the deal is so much better
now and I understand that people like
well it's a job okay it's a job if you
don't have to pay taxes on it you can't
get fired from it and you can only work
20 hours a week would you sign up for a
job that maybe you 19th at night might
not even bring qualified for the answer
is yes absolutely and so I just get
offended by new some same they don't get
anything
draymond Green say it's a dictatorship
when it's a voting body all the
universities which is the opposite of a
dictatorship and this idea that there's
a dark darkonian Empire that spits the
ruler that there's running this thing
and really all they're trying to do is
provide the most scholarships for the
kids and give them great opportunity so
the rest their lives they can be like me
and live off a four year basketball
career but I think was above average and
use that to promote my name image or
likeness forever
I just feel honored to have been a part
of it and I think we're creating this
era of entitlement where kids are so
we're gonna pay hight college kids let's
play the high school kids by modern day
right down the street from me their
quarterbacks now going to Alabama well
hey they're not making money off and of
course they are well why can't he get
his you know they're killing soldiers so
I can he can make because that's how
we're doing here so if when does it end
and I think that we're pushing towards
the beginning of the end of collegiate
sports and trying to professionalize it
which is a mistake it's not what it's
about it's about trying to equal out
those educational playing fields yeah we
were worried about the Olympics with
amateurism they got paid it didn't run
it how many well basketball I'm talking
about the other sports I wasn't worried
about the basketball players I'm worried
about the other sports you know I think
I don't think gymnastics is ruined I
don't think that figure skating is
ruined because somebody gets paid you
know basketball you can say oh okay are
the stars gonna play you know but you
also not educating and I don't know I
actually don't know the rules of
gymnastics out there professionals
religion I'd be lying if I said so I
mean and the reason we cheer for our
Olympians really is the Stars and
Stripes so it's kind of be honest more
and we learned didn't ruin it didn't
ruin the Olympics
everybody was hopeful you can't do it no
but like the amount of kids that are
getting an education getting a chance
like we can we can go through and talk
about all the people who don't have a
degree it made it in life but let's just
be honest you know in in this century
and beyond you better have that paper
you better have those resources you have
you know your sports family to call upon
it gives you a much it gives you a head
up and everything and then like look if
you want to be a coach high school
college gonna have to have three so I
again it will will will pain one kid
like no but the system as it fans works
and by the way if you don't like it you
don't have to do it there is no rule
that says you have to go to college as
basketball player football player as a
probably there's no rule it says you
have to go there's no rule it says you
have to go yeah but you want to go this
is the way you have to go so house an 18
you will get to the end of him I don't
know that's an NFL rule and by the way
it the whole thing works because they're
not goodness they can't have a
minor-league system well I can't do have
my we'll see of the XFL which is the
best possible shot of it working why
don't we just get it why do we have the
NCAA why doesn't the blender the power
five conferences just to seed and have
their own conference their own rules and
then you if you're good enough to be
brought in you know you could have
relegation there I mean why is the NCAA
still the governing body I don't you're
gonna have a governing body whatever
like so what do you get rid of a you'll
have a governing body of the power of
five yeah you're still gonna have the
haves and have-nots just as a difference
but we already have that we have the
haves and have-nots so why not let my
not do you know the elephants in the
room what are they what are they doing
that that what what what is the what is
the NCAA specifically it's like this is
kind of what we do we don't like
Congress or like yesterday do you think
the NCAA is you know valid do you think
that they're still powerful do you think
they make a difference yeah I think it's
a bureaucracy like anything else
I think there's rules that don't make
sense that coaches have complained about
and all sudden comes to fruition and
they didn't realize it like they have if
it's exact same thing is the NFL knew
pass interference rule right where you
can review passing parents I'm sure at
the you know in the heart of hearts the
NFL and al river on just wanted to not
screw up like the New Orleans Rams game
but by creating this rule
now sudden there's all these unintended
circumstance I got it like all of these
NCAA rules that's all that's all it is
no is it a bureaucracy yes is the robo
to sent yes but generally the idea is
you know don't pay your players right
you know don't change their grades and
you know you're trying to give everybody
a shot even though we know at the end of
the day there's gonna be five schools in
college basketball and you know five
schools and college football that
because they've been successful and they
provide their kids resources and their
location matters as well
they're gonna be better than everybody
else well we've been paying we've been
paying players for a long time you know
that we've been changing grades for a
long time do don't do that don't do that
you don't think we've been paying
players I think far fewer players the
everybody does it is what cheater sighs
I'm saying no we have I didn't say
everybody Doug I didn't say everybody
I'm saying that if a kid a high end kid
is going to a program I assume money is
being exchanged again that's that's an
ill-fated assumption I believe that's
not fair I like my eyes I like my odds I
think most I think most guys I think
most kids go to class I think most kids
I didn't say they didn't go to class I'm
just saying that money somehow with the
shoes being involved in this money
exchange we have guys going to jail
because of this Doug we got I agree guys
good went too crazy but but but this is
there was a government investigation and
when you consider how big the government
said their investigation was and how
little in terms of evidence they come up
with either college basketball coaches
are the greatest cheaters in LA in the
history of the United States or really
not that many people teeth and everybody
knows who that 10 or 15 schools are in
college football and you know 25 or 30
schools are in college basketball and
really it's usually a kid here a kid
there that people know who has their
hands down all right not everybody does
it but you know it is still prevalent
you know it goes on okay that's all I
didn't I didn't put a blanket down and
said everybody does it I'm saying it
goes on and you know it does all right I
gotta go I did Thank You Don Doug
Gottlieb Fox Sports for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]